[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 8 novembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78
les titres de cette édition une
convention signée ce matin au chainel
vise à lutter contre l'insécurité dans
les exploitations agricoles des yvelines
une vingtaine d'entre elles a subi des
vols depuis le début de l'année les
précisions en début de journal 35 ans
qu'il agit pour les droits des femmes et
des familles dans le département le
cidff des yvelines fête son anniversaire
demain c'est au lycée d'hôtellerie de
guyancourt l'occasion de rappeler les
domaines d'intervention de l'association
pour en parler
lucie robin elle est notre invité c'est
la directrice du cidff 78 et puis nous
recevons également dans cette édition
amélie et drouin directrice de l'antenne
ile de france ouest du labo des
histoires l'association propose des
ateliers d'écriture créative pour les
moins de 25 ans hier l'antenne est
inaugurée officiellement à versailles
après un an d'activité depuis le début
de l'année une vingtaine d'exploitations
agricoles a été victime de vol dont les
yvelines vol de matériel et de fioul qui
impacte directement la productivité des
agriculteurs c'est pour lutter contre ce
phénomène qui a été signé ce matin au
chesnay une convention de coopération
entre le monde agricole le la préfecture
des yvelines et les gendarmes du
département
c'était à la chambre d'agriculture
interdépartementale d'île de france sur
place marie pannetrat et aurélie ronces
trois signatures pour mieux lutter
contre l'insécurité qui touche le monde
agricole dans les yvelines
cette convention permet de mener
davantage d'actions entre les gendarmes
et les exploitants agricoles l'accent
est notamment mis sur la proximité en
fait on formalise des bonnes pratiques
un des bonnes pratiques qui ont déjà
lieu notamment en termes de par exemple
de prévention des vols avec des
gendarmes qui sont spécialisés dans le
conseil aux agriculteurs c'est à dire
qu'ils vont aller dans une exploitation
agricole et ils vont
faire des préconisations d'équipement
vidéoprotection en
fermeture de porte en tout ce qui permet
de ralentir en fait aux délinquants pour
l'année en cours on dénombre une
vingtaine de vols dans les exploitations
agricoles du département
le matériel agricole vos extrêmement
cher c'est à dire que pour un ordre
d'idée un tracteur et un tracteur
agricole c'est plus de 100000 euros donc
une moissonneuse batteuse c'est le prix
d'une maison à peu près donc quand vous
avez des engins qui ont une valeur de ce
type là dans les exploitations ça ça
vous montre qu'il ya en plus qui sont
mobiles c'est pas comme une maison donc
qu'ils peuvent se déplacer pour nous
l'aspect sécurité devient très important
une convention particulièrement
importante pour le département des
yvelines
composé à 40 % d'exploitations agricoles
est à peu près mille agriculteurs et ça
je parle de des exploitants agricoles
mais après vous avez toutes les familles
tous les sous traitants tous ceux qui
travaillent avec les agriculteurs donc
ça fait effectivement un nombre
considérable de personnes qui sont
concernées par cette convention
reconductibilité convention pourrait
intégrer de nouveaux volets destiné à
renforcer les liens entre les gendarmes
et les agriculteurs il souffle sa 35ème
bougies le cidff des yvelines centre
d'information sur le droit des femmes et
des familles célèbre son anniversaire ce
sera demain au lycée d'hôtellerie de
guyancourt bonsoir lucie robin ça vous
êtes la directrice du cidff des yvelines
35 ans de présence sur le territoire
c'est un anniversaire important pour
l'association c'est un anniversaire
important effectivement 35 ans sur le
territoire c'est commence à faire alors
depuis la naissance du cidff dans les
yvelines en 1982 on imagine beaucoup de
de progrès heureusement à sur cette
question des droits des femmes et des
familles est ce qu'il reste aujourd'hui
beaucoup à faire encore sur sur la
question witch tale fait on est à 13000
personnes reçues par an à peu près dont
4000 victimes ça vous donne une idée de
la charge de travail de l'association
oui beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
travail dans le département est ce que
ces derniers temps vous avez senti alors
je pense moins à la faire
vannes stein la révélation de l'affairé
bcia est ce que ces derniers temps vous
avez senti peut-être une libération de
la parole aux prêts je pense aux femmes
est ce que cette révélation de la faire
et tout ce qu'elle a engendrée après je
pense à la stag balances ton port la
révélation aussi de d'autres à faire sur
le sujet est ce que vous avez senti que
la parole se libérer dans les yvelines
oui oui la parole se libère mais déjà
depuis plusieurs années on voit qu'il ya
de plus en plus de manifestations
enfin de dénonciation de faits on le
voit au niveau du nombre d'augmentations
de nos victimes aussi serait qu'on
s'interrogeait ce qui a plus de victimes
ou est-ce que simplement les victimes en
parle plus je pense qu'il ya une grosse
partie de personnes qui osent plus
parler aujourd'hui elle se sent plus en
sécurité le haut se parler pourquoi
comment on peut expliquer justement
quels lots de plus sinon de
sensibilisation tout simplement déjà qui
inquiète les personnes à témoigner et à
parler
et puis effectivement quand il ya des
affaires comme ça qu'ils sortent on voit
nous aussi le nombre d'appels qui va
augmenter aussi au sein de l'association
des personnes qui osent plus en parler
alors le cidff des yvelines propose un
accès gratuit aux droits et il ya de
nombreux domaines d'intervention c'est
ça oui tout à fait on a plusieurs
secteurs d'intervention donc on a une
équipe de juristes qui interviennent sur
le volet accès au droit et aide aux
victimes
une équipe de psychologues qui elles
sont vraiment spécialisé dans la prise
en charge des victimes d'infractions et
puis on a des conseillers emploi aussi
cinq conseillers emploi qui
interviennent en grande partie sur
secteur de saint quentin en yvelines
dans l'accompagnement au poids des
femmes et pour préciser les choses au
pour nos téléspectateurs le cidff des
yvelines fait partie en fait d'un réseau
national
tout à fait on fait partie de deux
fédérations dont la confédération
nationale des cidff puisque vous avez
des cidff dans chaque département de
france
et puis la fédération nationale france
victime donc il rassemble toutes les
associations des deux victimes de france
et d'ailleurs demain pour l'anniversaire
du cidff des civils il sera présent de
ghislaine corbin qui est la présidente
du réseau national voilà de la
présidente du réseau national dci des
fédérations des cdf et dans le
département des yvelines où il ya
combien d'antenne du
du cidff est présent 150 lieux de
permanence différents dans les yvelines
donc c'est vrai qu'on aille pas mal le
département donc plus précisément nous
pour notre agglomération saint quentin
en yvelines où est implantée la tv 78
iliad est aussi aussi des antennes qui
sont là il ya des antennes donc on a des
antennes sur le volet juridique d'accord
qu'on est présent mais on justice de
trappes de guyancourt et en maison de
quartier de la verrière et puis après
sur le champ de l'emploi on a notre
antenne bayeux bureaux d'accompagnement
individualisé vers l'emploi qui est à
trappes
et puis des permanences dans de nombreux
de nombreux lieux de l'agglomération
donc le cap emploi de trappes
quand ils ont quartier de la verrière la
maison enfin le centre social de magny
les hameaux entre autres et beaucoup
d'autres ça veut dire que chaque antenne
à sa spécificité
elle a des rôles particulier à chaque
fois et pourtant dès lors en fait on
fait le même travail sur chacune des
antennes et après c'est vrai que my le
territoire pour permettre aux habitants
d'être au plus près d'eux et puis aussi
aux personnes qui travaillent sur les
lieux et pour qui c'est plus simple si
de venir à côté de leur travail plutôt
qu'à côté du lieu où ils habitent
mais vous le disiez tout à l'heure
treize mille personnes reçues par le
cidff des yvelines qui sont l on l'a vu
4000 victimes le reste c'est elles sont
si le reste de ces personnes sont
on en demande d'information oui voilà
une grande majorité du public que l'on
reçoit c'est vraiment sur les demandes
d'accès au droit
d'accord donc beaucoup de questions en
matière de droit de la famille tout ce
qui concerne les séparations les
questions d'autorité parentale
ça c'est vraiment la première des
questions qui qui est posée à nos
juristes et puis en deuxième partie le
droit du travail aussi de plus en plus
on est de plus en plus de questions sur
la thématique des licenciements des
démissions des ruptures conventionnelles
donc c'est majoritairement des questions
en matière d'accès au droit
en deuxième lieu l'aide aux victimes on
a vu quatre mille personnes sur sur ce
champ là donc là on est vraiment
majorité sur des femmes victimes de
violences conjugales beaucoup mais pas
que on va recevoir aussi les victimes
d'attentats des victimes d'escroquerie
abus de confiance faux mais là on est
très c'est vraiment tout victimes
d'infractions pénales
et puis en dernier lieu sur
l'accompagnement emploi on est à peu
près à cinq cents 500 femmes
accompagnées par an sur l'action de
l'emploi l'assaut final vous en parliez
il ya des juristes au sein de l'équipe
du cidff aussi des conseils emplois et
des psychologues
voilà exactement c'est ça on est une
équipe pluridisciplinaire sein du cidf
alors l'anniversaire dont qui se
déroulent devant le lycée d'hôtellerie
de guyancourt on imagine un événement
pour remercier les partenaires c'est
aussi pour rappeler le champ d'action du
cidff voilà c'est ça c'est exactement ça
et qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter
pour ce 35e anniversaire dernière
question est bien que tout se passe bien
et puis qu'on continue aussi à être
soutenue par nos partenaires parce que
c'est vrai que sans financement
l'association ne pourrait pas être là on
a commencé à trois salariés en 1982 on
et 21 aujourd'hui sur le territoire
donc on souhaite pouvoir poursuivre
notre action mieux vous souhaite de
continuer en tout cas merci à vous lucie
robin directrice du cidff des civils
joyeux anniversaire à votre association
qui fête ses 35 ans de présence dans les
yvelines et pour plus d'informations sur
la structure vous pouvez vous rendre sur
le site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran politique locale le prochain
conseil communautaire de saint quentin
en yvelines se tient le 16 novembre
devrait connaître lors de cette séance
l'ensemble des vice président de
l'agglomération ainsi que leur
délégation
le mois dernier le maire à l'est
républicain d'elancourt jean michel
fourgous est devenu le nouveau président
du territoire à 12 communes il a proposé
au maire de quatre villes des quatre
villes minoritaire de gauche de rentrer
dans l'exécutif une main tendue que va
vrai
semblablement accepté l'opposition à en
croire les propos de sandrine grand gang
conseillère communautaire
elle était notre invité hier dans le
journal on demande à participer à
l'exécutif on demande à être partie
prenante en fait de l'avenir de ce
territoire parce qu'on pèse aussi dans
ce territoire et puis qu'il ya des
clivages qui sont parfois indépendant de
des parcours politique qui sont liés au
territoire allemand donc ça paraissait
normal on a entendu la demande de
jean-michel fourgous qui est d'accepter
cette cette proposition de participer
après il ya il ya une charte de
gouvernance qu'on veut vraiment mettre
en place avec nos collègues pour que ça
marche
dès que d'émotions en doc ya encore des
négociations à la fois sur les
périmètres et puis sur sur comment on
fait comme on travaille à 12
et là il faut avancer avec les tous les
maires mais sur le principe je crois
qu'il ya un accord qui se dessine c'est
une problématique rencontrée par de
nombreuses centre-ville en grande
couronne francilienne la disparition de
leur commerce de proximité pour faire
subsister ces commerces les communes
tentent de trouver des solutions
innovantes comme à guyancourt avec cette
nouvelle campagne d'affichage nicolas
d'andry nicolas kirillovitch et patrick
jacques de dixmude sur un air des
beatles voici la nouvelle affiche que
les habitants de guyancourt vont pouvoir
découvrir dans leur ville un bout chez
une fleuriste ou encore un boulanger ils
ont tous le sourire pour une opération
de communication qui vise à les mettre
en avant
les habitants disent marquée de commerce
de proximité et être en concurrence avec
ses grandes surfaces donc la ville a
décidé de communiquer communiquer et de
mettre aussi en valeur ces petites
structures qui sont dans nos centres
vivre à guyancourt 140 commerces de
proximité sont présents sur l'ensemble
de la ville un chiffre important pour
vingt-huit mille habitants et qui prouve
que les petits commerçants résiste face
aux grandes enseignes
c'est le cas de ce pressing qui profite
des nouvelles constructions de logements
et de la présence des entreprises à
proximité
la clientèle et giresse est
essentiellement des jeunes
qui dépendent beaucoup du technocentre
qui est à côté ça fait tourner la maison
d'après ça fait tourner la boulangerie
dirait on les connaît tous et une petite
famille situation différente en revanche
à quelques mètres de là au centre ville
les problèmes de stationnement sont
pointés du doigt par les commerçants
aujourd'hui on n'a que trois places de
parking pour quatre commerces pour
capturer un score jeudi quatre commerces
et boulangeries pharmacies coiffure
boucherie je parle pas du détroit
restaurant je parle pas de deux voiles
alors ils vont vous dire on en a fait
derrière l'église sauf que pour aller
derrière l'église faut faire le tour
complet
selon un récent rapport remis au
gouvernement le taux de vacance
commercial toucherait 10 % des commerces
de centre ville à guyancourt ce taux ne
dépassent pas les 7% mais les deux
passions histoire et cosmétiques c'est
le pari pris par deux fermes arcier deux
pharmaciens de versailles ils ont lancé
début octobre mademoiselle saint germain
c'est une marque de cosmétiques et des
produits réalisés en partenariat avec le
potager du roi et l'école nationale
supérieure du paysage patrick jacques de
dixmude et mélanie poker une plante
aromatique qui donne bonne mine
ce romarin historique et cultivé au
potager du roi et depuis un mois ils se
retrouvent dans trois produits de beauté
d'un couple versailles et ils étaient
utilisés d'abord par charles 5 et louis
xiv à la fois pour donc comme au
médicinales qui était à la fois but est
à la fois donc utilisé sur les plaies
pour les désinfecter et puis plus tard
par madame de sévigné qui ont utilisé à
la fois pour son maître sur le visage
comme aux cosmétiques cette fois à la
fois aux 6% parfumé et plus tard c'est
jean louis fargue on le parfumeur de
marie antoinette qui revisite à l'eau de
la reine de hongrie qui est donc un
hydrolat de romarin pour en faire un
parfum un projet né en juillet 2016
grâce à un partenariat avec le potager
du roi et l'école nationale supérieure
du paysage un an et demi de recherche et
de développement
je suis pharmacien issus de
l'industrie pharmaceutique et je me
disais tous les jours en passant ici dix
ans le potager du roi est un espace
naturel vraiment remarquable qui
contient une diversité botanique d'une
haute qualité et
comment ça se fait que jusqu'à
aujourd'hui personne n'est plus utilisé
dans la fabrication de produits
cosmétiques les produits de la jeune
marque sont pour le moment disponibles
dans six points de vente versailles et
et parisiens charles cracco et ça compte
pas une pensent déjà à leur prochaine
création autour du concombre blanc de
bonneil on reste à versailles hier a été
inauguré officiellement à l'antenne ile
de france ouest de l'association le labo
des histoires c'était à l'atelier
numérique en présence notamment du maire
de la ville françois de mazières
le labo des histoires propose des
ateliers d'écriture pour les moins de 25
ans on en parle dans cette interview
avec notre invité amélie édoin bonsoir
non ça vous êtes la directrice de cette
antenne ile de france ouest du labo des
histoires alors inauguration officielle
de l'antenne hier mais l'association est
implantée à versailles depuis un an
depuis septembre 2016 pourquoi attendre
finalement un an pour faire cette
inauguration officielle
alors on a attendu un an pour faire une
inauguration parce qu'on n'était pas
implantée l'atelier numérique
initialement on a été très généreusement
accueillis à la bibliothèque centrale
par son directeur vincent régulier et on
a ensuite changé de bureau pour
l'atelier numérique pour prendre nos
quartiers avoir un espace d'ateliers
dédiés donc ça a pris un petit peu de
temps l'inauguration en tout cas hier où
et de ses nouveaux quartiers à l'atelier
numérique et est étant aussi lancé les
choses j'imagine en un ans de travail de
lancer nos premiers ateliers
on a fait des ateliers réguliers à
l'atelier numérique depuis maintenant un
an
c'était aussi le challenge de voir si ça
prenait au niveau de la population si
les enfants du quartier venaient et
c'était l'idée de proposer vraiment des
ateliers de proximité on voit des
imaginaires l'inauguration et de vos
locaux de l'atelier numérique comment
elle s'est passée cette inauguration
s'est s'était bonnes choses au programme
oui alors on a eu une inauguration en
soirée ça nous a permis de faire une
petite programmation intéressante on a
eu les discours de remerciements tout
d'abord et puis ensuite on a une table
ronde avec nos partenaires
balanins de l'escale à mantes la jolie
et puis vincent et gueuler pour les
bibliothèques de la ville de versailles
on a mis en mis en lumière par dont
toutes les médiations possible qu'on
peut proposer au public
on a eu ensuite une restitution de mai
intervenants qui sont venus cela mais et
chanter sur scène kalimat et olivier au
long je les remercie et puis on a exposé
les textes des laborantins à les clips
laborantins qui sont les jeunes qui
participent aux ateliers exactement
celle de notre code pour nos
participants laborantins et laborantines
puisqu'il ne faut pas oublier et jeune
fille qui viennent et on a exposé leurs
travaux
à cette occasion alors la bo des
histoires sin associations l'adie 1 qui
propose des ateliers d'écriture créative
ces ateliers gratuits et ce pour les
moins de 25 ans alors la particularité
c'est que ces ateliers sont animés par
des professionnels de l'écriture aussi
bien des auteurs des bédéistes ça peut
être aussi des journalistes des
scénaristes ces voix là c'est aussi
cette particularité
oui alors on a souhaité que nos ateliers
soient tous animés par des
professionnels la chaîne du livre de
l'écriture on c'est un gage de qualité
et puis c'est leur travail donc c'est
eux qui sont en mesure de pouvoir
intervenir en direct avec les jeunes et
leur donner des conseils qui sont et
bienveillant et surtout professionnel
l'idée c'est aussi de faire des ateliers
d'écriture sous toutes leurs formes là
on l'a vu enfin je les cités des
journalistes des scénaristes il ya
d'autres formes d'écriture que
l'écriture de romans par exemple mais
alors on a des auteurs c'est vrai je
pense à quilly bébé ou bien frédéric
couderc qui sont un peu connue quand
même qui viennent là très généreusement
nous intervenir auprès de nos jeunes
mais on a effectivement des scénaristes
on a des journalistes et l'idée c'est de
proposer l'écriture sous toutes ses
formes donc d'avoir des courts métrages
qui sont réalisés après d'avoir de
l'écriture numérique d'avoir du codage
par exemple d'avoir des chansons et des
restitutions qui sont un petit peu
différente d'un recueil très très
classique je dirais on nous parle
souvent de l'importance de la lecture
pourquoi l'écriture écrire de manière
régulière est il primordial l'écriture
je pense que d'abord l'écriture amène à
la lecture et la lecture et l'écriture
ya force et la beauté des passerelles
nous notre implantation dans une
bibliothèque mais l'écriture permet
avant tout de pouvoir se livrer et puis
d'avoir davantage confiance en soi et ça
peut être un exutoire pour dire tout ce
qu'on a pas eu envie de faire dans la
journée pour dire ce qui ne va pas ou
bien dire ce qui va et nous le but c'est
de proposer l'écriture sous toutes ses
formes est de proposer un rapport plus
positif à l'écriture pour des publics
qui pourraient peut-être être plus
négatif sur ce qu'elle écrit au
quotidien
et comment se déroulent les ateliers
c'est à la carte ya plusieurs types
d'ateliers qui sont proposés exactement
à des ateliers dans nos bureaux ou les
jeunes s'inscrivent sur notre site
internet ou via la bibliothèque
et puis on a des ateliers dans un public
qui et je dirai captifs mais parce que
ça se passe dans leur école ça se passe
dans les hôpitaux dans la maison d'arrêt
des femmes
donc c'est un public qui ne peut a
priori pas sortir et venir dans nos
locaux dont il va chez eux
hélas les ateliers se font sur la
demande de nos partenaires et ça c'est
sur le territoire de toute l'île de
france ouest ailleurs quatre
départements le val le val d'oise les
hauts-de-seine les yvelines et l'essonne
tel territoire de l'académie de
versailles finalement exactement nous
sommes trois à rayonner sur la région
ile de france je m'occupe de l'île de
france ouest j'ai une collègue qui se
chargent du pendant est et puis notre
antenne historique sur paris je couvre
quatre départements
malgré l'implantation yvelinoise on
travaille sur les quatre départements
et si on devait faire enfin si vous
deviez dresser un petit bilan de
l'activité de l'année dernière ça c'est
ça s'est bien déroulé ces ateliers pour
le labo des histoires la révolte a fait
puisque je suis assez heureuse et fière
de le dire puisque on organisait presque
270 atelier sur les quatre départements
et on a eu un peu près de 1600
bénéficiaires et si on prend versailles
j'ai un petit peu calculé avant devenir
pro versailles depuis qu on y implanter
on a organisé une centaine d'ateliers et
on a accueilli presque 800 bénéficiaires
en moins d'un an
donc c'est plutôt très très positif et
ça veut dire que l'écriture plaît
toujours autant sur le territoire d
des ateliers à versailles vous l'avez
dit aussi sur sur tout le territoire je
pensais aussi à lille lyne rural le sud
yvelines s'est il ya des ateliers sont
organisés aussi sur ce territoire
exactement alors moi j'ai un axe
stratégique de développement puisque je
travaille sur des départements qui sont
aussi bien l'euro que citadins
l'objectif c'est d'aller dans les toutes
petites communes aussi donc on a
travaillé avec le parc naturel régional
de la haute vallée de chevreuse on y
organisait des ateliers pendant les
journées européennes du patrimoine
et puis on a aussi un petit camion qui
s'appelle le labo mobile et que j'ai eu
le plaisir d'inaugurer en mars dernier
avec une souris dans les yvelines et
l'objectif c'était d'aller dans les
petites villes avec qui ont des
structures culturelles réduite mais qui
ont tout un tas de public qui nous
attendent on a travaillé à abîme des
ailes et saint-hernin dernière minute de
cet entretien quels sont les prochains
temps forts dans les élus les prochains
ateliers organisés
alors on invite tous les jeunes ont très
vite et 25 ans qui ont envie de
participer à nos ateliers le 21 et le 23
novembre prochain pour des ateliers
autour de l'univers de carole très bord
à la bibliothèque porchefontaine de
versailles
et puis pour tous ceux qui auraient
envie entre 8 et 12 ans on a un atelier
le mercredi 29 novembre à l'atelier
numérique sur l'univers de jules verne
il faut s'inscrire au préalable alors on
s'est inscrits soit bien les
bibliothèques on chanta nous l'atelier
numérique soit via le site internet qui
s'affiche d'ailleurs en bas de l'écran
merci à mme ailier droit d'aller avec
nos directrice ile de france ouest de
l'association
le labo des histoires et retrouver un
toutes les informations sur le site
internet de l'association information
insolite
avant de refermer ce journal dont je me
suis perdu dans mes feuilles le prochain
sujet est consacrée à génération écran
si une exposition et qui se tient en ce
moment même au musée de la ville elle
est consacrée à la télévision à la
télévision qui a traversé de nombreuses
générations on n'y a vécu notamment
l'arrivée de la couleur ou encore les
premiers pas de l'homme sur la lune
c'est un sujet signé et camille lambert
[Musique]
pour les plus jeunes ces téléviseurs
peuvent avoir l'air de venir d'un autre
monde des années 50 aujourd'hui la
télévision a bien changé dans son
contenu et dans sa forme en témoigne ce
pique nique ce téléviseurs de philips a
connu son heure de gloire dans les
années 60
c'est un téléviseur qui date de 1969 et
qui est tout à fait emblématique de
l'évolution du poste de télévision dans
les années 60 avec l'apparition de
nouveaux matériaux comme notamment le
plastique qui remplace le bois de la
génération précédente
et puis cette forme tout à fait épuré
futuriste vous faites dans une
simplicité de deux formes
c'est dans les années 70 que les
français s'équipent massivement de ce
nouveau média
le musée de la ville raconte son
histoire dans une exposition
le rôle de la télévision a été
essentielle lors de la création de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines notamment par
l'intermédiaire du crabe et de la bac ce
qu'ils étaient
des associations des structures locales
qui ont permis d'utiliser l'audiovisuel
et en particulier l'image télévisuelle
comme outil d'expression la population
vis-à-vis de la construction de 7,8
cette ville nouvelle qui était en train
de se construire un retour nostalgique
au temps où les téléviseurs trôner
fièrement dans les salons
c'est désormais dans nos poches où notre
sac qu'il se décline une nouvelle
génération toujours aussi porté sur les
écrans un sujet sur cette expo
télévision de camille lambert et mélanie
poker je l'avais oublié juste avant lui
passe aujourd'hui sur notre petit écran
il a 15 ans et évolue déjà au niveau
national qui élit ce very permet aux
yvelines d'être représenté au
championnat de france de breakdance
c'est le 18 novembre prochain dans le
nord-pas-de-calais une aventure pour ce
jeune sportif accompli avec surtout
derrière le soutien indéfectible de sa
famille sujet de marylène iapichino et
nicolas d'andrus des étirements de la
concentration et des prises de notes à
l'âge de 15 ans kelis prend ses
entraînements au sérieux l'enjeu est de
taille il est qualifié pour le
championnat de france de break dance
alors pour être prêt la stratégie bien
rodée au début de l'entraînement je mets
mes sont à moi et que j'ai dans ma
playlist
je mets au hasard et en fait après au
milieu de l'entraînement je vais sur
youtube et je mets des sons que je
connais pas pour que je puisse m'y
habituer à danser sur différents styles
de fond parce que ça va pas toujours
être le même son cette discipline il la
partage avec toute sa famille quand les
coaches ne sont pas là ce sont ses
frères des soeurs eux-mêmes break dancer
qui corrige ses gestes avec une grande
publicité
c'est vrai qu'on nous dit souvent qu'on
est lié on a souvent des
des codes pour se motiver et puis nos
training ils sont faut savoir qu'ils
sont jamais vraiment vraiment sérieux en
général on fait toujours un peu les
qu'on en fait on est lié et c'est ça qui
nous rend qui fait un peu notre force
budget en sportif accompli qui listent
rock parfois les baskets de breakdance
pour les crampons il évolue comme milieu
droit dans l'équipe de
voisins-le-bretonneux depuis septembre
c'est vraiment un sport qui me plaisent
j'aime bien la vitesse tout ce qui est
jeu technique et ce que j'aime surtout
c'est d'esprit d'équipé
surtout quand on allume une fois encore
kelis n'est pas seule sa famille est au
bord du terrain pour l'encourager on
laisse vraiment tout le temps au
quotidien après on lui parle aussi de de
se détendre un peu à côté de pas que
penser à ça parce que après sinon ça
fonctionne pas donc on est vraiment là
au quotidien
peu importe skis à voile rendez vous le
18 novembre sur la piste de danse de
liévin dans le pas de calais pour les
championnats de france de breakdance
kelis blessé l'année dernière a hâte
d'affronter ses adversaires
[Musique]
avant de refermer ce journal cette
information insolite dont jeu et j'ai
commencé à vous parler à tout à l'heure
hec champion français des écoles de
commerce et aussi des rencontres en
ligne
l'établissement de jouy en josas arrive
en tête d'un classement des campus qui
compte le plus d'utilisateurs de tender
à l'application permet de faire des
rencontres avec le principe du sweep
autrement dit il s'agit de balayer du
doigt son écran pour accepter ou non un
profil hec paris qui compte près de 4500
étudiants le classement ne dit pas bien
sûr s'ils ont tous trouvé l'âme soeur
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
retrouvé à cette édition en replay sur
notre site internet et sur notre
application mobile tablette tv 78 très
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]